it's been described as the donation of
the century
a treasure trove of art that includes
works by some of the world's most
renowned and sought-after masters
combined with the most famous of korean
artists
both modern and classical in addition
a vast wealth of artifacts charting
korea's cultural heritage
spanning hundreds of years of dynastic
rule
this is an unprecedented large-scale
donation it is meaningful in enriching
the cultural assets of this museum
the cunhi not only devoted his life to
making samsung a global brand
but also to building one of the world's
largest private art collections
following his death last october it was
announced his family would pay a record
inheritance tax bill
of 10 billion dollars at the same time
donating to the nation
a sizeable part of the private art
collection
totaling 23 000 pieces
[Music]
collection can be called a miracle of
the world it will invigorate our
donation culture
rewrite the history of modern and
contemporary korean art and enrich us
all
a committee set up to choose a permanent
home for the collection
has decided upon a specially built
museum in
seoul rejecting attempts by provinces
across
south korea to be chosen and the current
predicament
facing lee's son and the de facto head
of samsung
has added further controversy y lee
is currently serving a two and a half
year prison sentence
in a long-running high-profile bribery
case
there's been widespread speculation the
donation of this art
could be part of a behind-the-scenes
deal to get him released
critics say there shouldn't be any kind
of deal and jay
lee should serve his full term but
certainly the size of this gift
means the lee family's popularity has
increased significantly
with a recent poll showing a majority of
people in favor of granting lee a pardon
whatever the immediate impact of this
donation
the artistic riches on offer are certain
to thrill appreciative art lovers
for generations to come rob mcbride al
jazeera
seoul